this project is not about nostalgia this
project
is about fact and it's looking at
polaroid
not only as an art not only as a
technology but also
as a business as an industry as a
visual system i thought i would start
with
a work by uh esp walker
i'll call him sam i know him as sam sb
walker
and it's called blacked out polaroid
sign 2011.
and it's a far cry from
the snappy clean pristine
polaroid logos we continue to see on our
lives
it's it comes as a bit of a shock and i
decided to talk to sam directly
he wrote me an email i asked him quickly
to give me a sort of sense of
how he came to make this particular
picture and i think it's so interesting
i'm going to read it out to you quickly
so sam writes the basic outline is that
back in 2010
2011 i'd periodically drive by the old
polaroid campus on 128 in waltham
at this point in time the company had in
effect gone under
and the campus was in a state of
dereliction and it very much felt like
the end of an era
for the medium the campus came to
represent that for me
in a very physical way and it became
necessary to capture that moment
when the first developer bought it they
didn't bother to take the sign down
they just had someone crudely black it
out with spray paint
to me it became a powerful metaphor for
the state of the company
and by extension analog photography in
general
so i knew i just had to make an image of
it my first attempt was to capture it in
one
frame you'll see that there's five
capture it in one frame
but it forced me to be too far away and
the glow
and the texture of the sign was not
apparent
so one day i decided to return with a
small ladder
and a crappy folding table so i could
raise the level of my tripod to the
height of the sign
it was an overcast morning and i
proceeded to carefully frame and capture
the sign
in five parts given the precarious
nature of setting a tripod on a table
it's a miracle it came out as well as it
did the fact that i could see the
positives and the negatives right on the
spot gave me confidence that i was
getting the result i wanted
it goes without saying but that was the
great beauty and advantage of using
polaroid so
when i first saw this picture i thought
perhaps
oh it's a an artistic uh intervention
you know that he's taken the original
polaroid sign and
painted over and so on and that
interested me much less
um as a concept when i discovered it was
a documentary picture
and yet so it's aesthetically uh
pleasing
i got very excited and and a phrase from
i've been reading about
humphrey davey the sir humphrey davy the
famous victorian scientist
and a phrase came to mind and it goes
like this every discovery
opens a new field for investigation of
facts
shows us the imperfection of our
theories
it is justly being said that the greater
the circle of light
the greater the boundary of darkness by
which it is surrounded
and it seemed almost that comfy davey
was was talking about this picture
you